President Trump is at his New Jersey
golf club ahead of this week's trip to
an economic summit in Germany he's
expected to meet informally with the
Russian President Vladimir Putin during
those talks mr. Trump spoke on the phone
last night with Japanese Prime Minister
and Chinese president as well who will
also attend the g20 summit the White
House says they talked about the North
Korean nuclear threat before that mr.
Trump spent much of the weekend lashing
out at the media including a tweeted
video that outraged many of his critics
chip Reid is at the White House where
the president's advisors are defending
his message chip good morning well good
morning the president's latest
controversial tweet comes a day after he
proclaimed on Twitter that my use of
social media is not presidential
it's modern-day presidential so welcome
to the modern age the fake media is
trying to silence us but we will not let
them President Trump kept the focus on
his favorite target over the weekend the
media the fake media tried to stop us
from going to the White House but I'm
president and they're not Sunday morning
the president posted a video on Twitter
showing him bashing the CNN logo
originally from 2007 the video shows
them citizen Trump attacking a wrestling
executive it's unclear who made the new
version it was first posted on Reddit
five days ago by a user whose past
postings have threatened violence
against Muslims in response CNN called
it a sad day when the President of the
United States encourages violence
against reporters he is involved in
juvenile behavior far below the dignity
of his office I think that no one would
perceive that as a threat I hope they
don't but I do think that he's beaten up
in a way on on cable platforms that he
has a right to respond to Homeland
Security Advisor Thomas Bossert defended
the president so I'm pretty proud of the
president for developing a Twitter and a
social media platform where he can talk
directly to the American people
Democrats and Republicans criticized mr.
Trump late last week it's been
fascinating for his personal attacks on
MSNBC co-host Joe Scarborough and Mika
Brzezinski this is maddening
that's mending ly frustrating Delaware
Democrat Tom Carper said the tweets show
a lack of leadership leaders don't build
themselves out by pushing other people
down the president ramped up his feud
against CNN after a couple of major
mistakes by the network last week
including a story about mr. Trump that
was later retracted causing three
reporters to resign Dana chip Reid at
the White House chip thank you